aloïs il souhaite et rêve je vous en
prie ne raccrochez pas c'est très
important il faut que vous parlez je
vous écoute et souhaite détresse ajouté
ajouté les fans fassent doute le
téléphone vous téléphone parce qu'ils
aient confiance
détendez vous allez d'accord voilà
geneviève et moi enfin ma femme et moi
on s'est séparés et comme tous les
ennuis arrivent en même temps j'ai perdu
mon emploi
alors comme vous le voyez il s'agit
d'une situation banale très banal même
mais cette situation je dois y a pas de
situation
d'accord il y a que des moments des
faits qu'ils continuent de percer voilà
et tous ces problèmes tous ces problèmes
ont provoqué des ennuis de santé pas
grave servi autant des gens oui ils ont
provoqué une crise de colite parce que
j'ai eu des animaux et depuis j'ai une
colite et à l'eau quand je suis fatigué
je sens son côté droit
une sorte de gêne avez vous changé à la
beauté de courir pieds nus
jo alors quand je suis en vacances je
suis crevé je dors avec comme je vous
disais je sens son côté droit une sorte
de gêne c'est à dire c'est pas vraiment
une gêne l'avez-vous de bonheur et à
pire et la magnificence d'un lever de
soleil
et bien justement ce matin j'ai des
ballonnements et je me sens vide il de
plus beau que d'écouter bêta avec un
être qu'on a
oui mais je ne viens devant mener la
chaîne stéréo elle a même emmené tout
l'électroménager j'ai gardé vrai ça veut
dire qu'on joue que nous ne sommes
jamais seuls l'ia l'amitié l'amour et
avez vous songé à quoi l'amour et donner
et recevoir et fin oui j'ai beaucoup
donné oui c'est vrai le plaisir d'aimer
je vous parle vous me répondez et c'est
déjà un échange qui nous rapproche c'est
vrai il faut dire qu'il ya dans votre
voix une grande tendresse vous êtes très
convaincante savez je voulais vous nous
avons de faire grand palun berland oui
je trouve est finalement très peu de
temps c'est sa 4e vidal
les veaux qu'ensemble nous construisions
votre avenir qu'est ce que voulait dire
ensemble les dire vous et moi ensemble
ce serait formidable a ajouté c'est la
première fois que je ris depuis très
longtemps
vous ne vous rendez pas compte on a fait
un très grand pas l'un vers l'autre
je ne sais pas si vous êtes ensemble
nous allons remonter la pente
je suis tout à fait d'accord red bull a
donc pensé si je la suis pas dingue dit
dit je voulais vous faire une
proposition
lorsque demain matin vous aurez terminé
votre travail est ce qu'on n'aurait pas
pu c'est une suggestion d'abord
s'adresser à l'agencé nationale on joue
non non moi ce qui m'intéresse à serait
de prendre mon petit déjeuner avec vous
face au soleil levant c'est une
suggestion que je me permets de naoufel
qu'on ne trouvait pas d'emploi dans
votre qualification nous pourrions
envisager un cycle un je m'en fous non
moi je suis ouvert à toutes les
suggestions pour vous que l'on parle
dans la fraîcheur de l'aube avec les
cris des oiseaux qui s'éveille enfin
voilà tout ça veut dire prêt à affronter
cette journée mais je vous dis y'a pas
il n'y a pas de problème on pourrait
même courir que les nus dans le jardin
des tuileries
c'est vous qui allez parler du pied nu
tout à l'heure le car arrive mais je
suis prêt je suis prêt ravet mais je
vous dis je suis prêt j'attends c'est
tous et rendez vous directement chez
vous si vous avez une chaîne stéréo
lorsque j'ai pas la chaîne nationale
pour la nationale pour l'emploi national
pour l'emploi national pour l'encours
nationale pour l'encours massot